I would make a quick note so you can put
a subheading before you start the
exercise but as it boots up there's one
really little confusing item that I want
to address head on before you get
started so you don't get confused about
it there are all kinds of certs when
you've got the square root of a cube
root sign and when you evaluate the
number of other okay so the square root
of a number let's just call the number
well in Algebra one you don't know what
a number is where you call it usually
usually called X okay square root of X
we define that as a positive number okay
the reason why is you've actually been
doing square roots for a really long
time attached to a particular kind of
shape is they don't remember what cash
APE requires square roots give you okay
if you have a right angle triangle right
let's make it a triangle
oh yeah okay in a right angle triangle
if you know two sides what do you do to
get to the last one you use Pythagoras
theorem which has squares and therefore
has square roots of it okay now I think
we all know what this number is going to
be right but where it comes from is it's
the square root of or in this case three
squared plus four squared
okay now here's the thing
it's a length right so therefore that
has to be positive
do you agree like lengths that you
measure out have to be positive so
therefore we define the square root of x
to always be positive
oops he is always positive except in a
single case there's only one number in
the entire universe that does not have a
positive value when you take its square
root does anyone know what it is
zero zero you can take the square root
of zero
what's the number that you multiply by
itself to give you zero and the answer
is 0 but 0 is not positive is it
negative
it's kind of neither which is a bit
strange
okay so this is the important note on
which you get down the squared of X is
always positive
except when x equals 0 so we know square
root of 100 it's positive square root of
256 positive square root of we don't um
Burres which give you something strange
positive but if you have the square root
of 0 that's the only one where you don't
get a positive number which then begs
the question well if the positive
numbers work and zero works what about
when you put something negative
underneath the square root sign what
happens
hmm now inquisitive and quick among you
go straight to your calculator and your
calculator will faithfully tell you
there's syntax error or math error right
which is a calculator saying a
calculator is way of saying okay so I
actually want to tell you it's more than
the calculator knows so underneath where
you talked about it being positive right
once you write down so the square root
of x is and put this in um put this in a
very common point is undefined when X is
negative now let me push on this a
little bit okay everything I'm supposed
to teach you then I'm required to teach
you as part of the attend syllabus is on
the board okay
that's what you have to know about the
square root of x this is what it does
when it's positive or zero when it's
negative don't worry about it
that's what the syllabus requires me
thank you however I want to push just a
little further I know then take me 60
seconds humor me a little bit what's
five take away three it's too right I'll
show you why
mmm-hmm five five take away catch one
two three I've taken away three is to do
you agree five take away 3 is to we're
fine with that
okay I need one of these back if we know
five take away 3 is 2
what's 3 take away 5 now points per
second before you say in answer you
actually can work out what the answer is
and you guys know enough math to be able
to repeat an answer back okay but my son
who is six at the moment and is learning
about adding and subtracting will tell
you you can't you can't because watch
three take away 5 is 1 2 3 can't do
anymore sorry
forget it no it's just because I don't
trust my throwing arm it's not forcing
away that's okay oh you can't do it you
can't do 3 take away 5 he would say you
know do you need to spend me he would
say 3 take away 5 is a definition for
that ok he's think you guys look there
is a definition for what what is it it's
negative 2 we like invent this new kind
of number to be the answer for this
there is an answer for this it's just
not one way going to explore just yet
just like my son hasn't learned about
negative numbers yet because I don't
want to blow his brain he will learn
about it eventually if you want to ask
me a question about what happens here
you're more than welcome to but this is
where you 10 sort of draws a line and
stare as well you can peek over behind
the veil if you want but we learn this
later on because I'm just going to
choose that all right I'm gonna pause
there you've all by now opened up term
101 you've got enough to understand
what's a certain what's not right have a
look on the board
how many certs are there on the board
just just look it's just there's just
one isn't there see which one of these
it's the one I asked you to work out the
squared 101 see all the rest these guys
why aren't they so
because they stopped alright so then
those regular numbers we knew before
whole numbers fractions they're fine
we're interested in these really weird
special ones